what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
comic book fans members of the robbed
core and people who stumbled across this
video man I left you guys on one heck of
a cliffhanger last week man you should
have seen those comments people were
like no it was hilarious but if you
thought that cliffhanger was bad man
would you see what we do at the end of
this video man anyway so uh so secret
Empire art to me there's two kinds of
comic-book stories there's good comic
book stories ones where you just like
it's kind of cool you know and then
there's like amazing kind of book
stories I don't really consider there to
be like that at counter book stories
because everybody's got something that
they enjoy about one story for the most
part like I know people who hated
spider-man Clone Saga and I know people
who loved it so there's no absolute
truth when it comes to story that's why
I say there's good and there's amazing
but in the last video when we did secret
Empire number two we had basically run
over this idea to Captain America I
guess you know Hydra Captain America
Steve Rogers was basically consolidating
his power he was you know trying to
figure out how to be an effective leader
of Hydra while dealing with the politics
of it all because there were members of
the Hydra council who were basically
saying hey look you have to make an
example of the various superheroes out
there there's somebody you just have to
kill whereas Steve Rogers said look and
we started killing off everybody then in
the general public will turn against us
and that was the beauty of it all that
was the beauty of the whole thing is it
was walking this very tight line Steve
Rogers has always historically been
extremely good when it came to tactics
whatever the case may be he always knew
the right direction to go in order to
effectively win or at least try his best
to win and he was really good at
rallying people to his cause and when he
basically you know his Hope House was
rewritten and he effectively became a
Hydra agent or at least that seemed to
be the case the idea was that when they
came to power they said okay look there
are things that we can do we can curb
you know what it is the people can I
can't do but we have to give them the
illusion that they stand some measure of
success and that was the reason why the
internet was maintained even with
Captain America as the head of Hydra and
Hydra being this you know fascist
dictatorship it was basically running
the show let the people have the
Internet if the people have the Internet
they'll have their own little groups and
their own little organizations and
they'll have their little you know
guerrilla warfare tactics and they'll be
stopped occasionally but you let them go
through with their plans that won't
actually do anything they can lost using
a little battle tactics and so on and so
forth they can take out a few Hydra
forces here and there but in the end
it's one step
forward two steps back they just don't
know that it's happening that's the goal
give people the illusion that they're
succeeding and they'll keep on fighting
and basically you'll be able to maintain
your own your own Empire so again it's
really genius in terms of how it all
unfolds but what this ends up doing is
this jumps back to the idea of the whole
vanishing point that's really the only
indication we've given of what this
place is and this is where we left off
on the last video because we have Hydra
Captain America who's basically
dominating the entire United States and
then suddenly we have this place off
somewhere that looks like a fantasy land
or we've got another version of Steve
Rogers we don't know who this Steve
Rogers is we know nothing about this guy
all he knows is he says my name is Steve
Rogers and I'm trying to get back home
now of course this coincided with the
arrival of just some girl we're not
given this girl's name we're not given
you know her relevance her significance
what's important here is that she's
there to basically juxtapose this
version of Steve Rogers with the version
of Steve Rogers that we've seen before
the one that's currently running Hydra
and the reason why is because of the
fact that Captain America as a concept
is not lost on writer Nick Spencer the
whole idea of Captain America is that
he's an ideology he is a perspective
he's a viewpoint he stands for something
greater than just a guy with a shield
dressed in the American flag running
around fighting on the side of freedom
that's the whole nature of this is this
designed to show us that this is
basically the Steve Rogers that we all
know and the reason why we get this is
because this girl simply asked do you
remember how you got here do you know
what's going on do you know what this
place is Steve Rogers response is no he
has no clue what it says the only thing
he recalls are the basics his military
training and that's the only explanation
we need that this is the Steve Rogers
that we for the most part know and love
because remember when the whole origin
of Hydra Captain America was being
rewritten this was basically removed and
instead he was brought up and he was
trained by Hydra and so again these are
two completely different origins for
these different characters and that's
how we differentiate between the two now
at this point again we basically jump
over to the idea of Peter quill and this
is kind of funny because River with
Captain America's Steve Rogers I guess
with a Hydra Captain America going
through and initiating this shield
that's capable of blocking out virtually
any threat this shield itself took into
account virtually every force that the
earth had ever come across Galactus
these various alien races so on and so
forth and so it made sense that they
would
that would be designed to withstand
those forces of what use would it be to
make a shield to protect the earth if
they didn't take into account people
with almost godlike levels of power that
should be able to get through it but
with Peter quill and the guardians of
the galaxy or at least Peter quill
Rocket Raccoon and group going out and
trying to basically find people they can
rally to their cause what this does is
it brings in the perception of earth
with regards to the rest of the universe
now again this is not new the earth has
always been viewed as a place that's the
other alien races across the universe
absolutely hate that goes all the way
back to the Chris Claremont era of the
x-men back in the 1970s and 1980s it's
always been that way the earth basically
houses these superheroes some of which
have insane levels of power but the
earth never really takes into account
how their actions affect the rest of the
universe and so again because of this is
always one of these things where the
earth battles the Earth's problems
ultimately spill out on to the rest of
the universe and all these other
different alien races either have to
play mop-up duty or they have to try to
basically run and flee for their lives
in order to avoid everything that the
earth is screwing up so again this
unfolds exactly as we would expect when
Peter Cole basically says hey look
here's everything that's going on ah
Captain America basically turned out to
be a bad guy he seized control of the
United States he created this giant
shield around the earth we need your
help in order to basically try to find a
way to take down the shield whether it's
using your technology or whatever the
case may be and they all say no and not
only do they say no they all start
attacking Peter quill because again it's
their chance to basically take the earth
down to keep it isolated because that's
the nature of this Peter quill is
basically making the argument and saying
hey look this won't stop here like Hydra
Captain America they're going to start
turning their attention to all of you
now keep in mind for the most part all
of these races have all manner of
technology that could easily be used to
basically destroy Hydra but at the same
time Captain America has some pretty
formidable heroes on his side as the
head of Hydra not all of them are there
because they want to be but regardless
of their motivations they are fighting
on his side and so again it's really
kind of a cool scenario because it
brings them this question of how far
it's Hydra Captain America really
willing to go in order to ensure that he
can basically bring peace to earth and
then eventually the universe now at this
point we switch over to a guy by the
name of Frederick and Frederick is
not very relevant at all Frederik Meijer
is a guy that goes by the name of
boomerang and he's literally like
Captain Boomerang from DC Comics it said
a lot less interesting
what is designed to be is basically here
to show us this is very much like the
old man Logan story remember in the old
man Logan story all the earth
superheroes died and villains who would
have normally had no real role in
society whatsoever suddenly found
themselves rising up and carving out
these little niches for themselves where
they could have their own little you
know quote-unquote
empires Hydra doesn't really care what
goes on on the ground level hydras out
up in the sky
they're up in the clouds so long as they
maintain their control they don't really
care what happens on the surface and
that's what's going on here with guys
like Frederik Meijer this is a
small-time criminal who managed to
basically kind of wheedle his way into
this huge amount of success just because
of the fact that there's really no
superheroes that are willing to step out
and fight anymore because either they're
being rounded up by Hydra or they're
just being killed on sight and so it
gives them this chance to basically
carve out his own little niche now him
meeting with Natasha Romanoff with Black
Widow is actually designed to
orchestrate a meet up between Black
Widow and somebody else and this person
is revealed to be Maria Hill now
something that I want you guys to notice
for a lot of you guys who are not
familiar with Marvel Comics this is one
of those Nick Fury moments if you've
been a really Marvel Comics for a long
time you know that like the original
Nick Fury before he became like you know
the unseen the old-school Nick Fury the
white guy with the eye patch and so on
and so forth he was one of these guys
where he was always like the last man
standing if everything went to pot Nick
and Nick Fury had all these bunkers
stationed all around the world and he
would just go there he would gather
Intel he would wait it out he would do
whatever it was he needed to do Maria
Hill is much the same way Maria Hill is
a character who basically found her huge
claim to fame when she became director
of shield prior to and was director
during the events of smuggles original
Civil War story everybody hated her like
people hated Maria hill during civil war
people were just like ah man I wish
Maria Hill would die but that was a
testament to how well her character was
written but she basically stayed
director of shield for a little while
after Civil War was over Tony Stark
became director of shield eventually he
was removed Norman Osborn became
director then he was removed and then
Maria Hill took his place and of course
this led into all-new all-different
marvel with Hydra Captain America
orchestrating things behind the scenes
so that Maria Hill would be ousted
and then he would take her place and
then initiate his whole plan to take
over the United States but she's always
been one of these characters is very
Nick Fury esque in terms of how she
functions and how she operates she's
able to use what little Intel she has at
her disposal in order to basically grab
the calendar of Steve Rogers now on the
surface it seems totally irrelevant but
the reason why this is important is
because of the fact we actually jump
over to Steve Rogers while he's speaking
with the members of hydras Council these
members of hydras council represent
different aspects some are in charge of
social media some are in charge of the
military but the idea here is that Steve
Rogers is still on the hunt for the
shards of the cosmic you remember those
were destroyed it's really the only way
to basically fix everything and set
things back to the way they're supposed
to be we end up finding out that one of
the charge resides in Atlantis so that's
why this is all happening is because
with the calendar of Hydra Captain
America effectively be former Avengers
that's what we want to call them
basically know exactly where he's going
to be at any given time during the day
and so they know exactly where he's
going what he's going to be searching
for the whole nine yards and this is
actually going to allow both teams to
converge and encounter one another
during the next issue which is actually
going to be kind of cool but the other
thing about this is that remember name
what a Submariner is hiding to a degree
he's trying to marshal his forces while
they're going around and capturing these
shards of the Cosmic Cube
Arnim Zola tried to invade Wakanda and
was almost immediately repelled black
panther waged absolutely pandemonium
against him with regards to name with a
Submariner while the forces of Baron
Zemo and those guys are trying to get in
there ultimately it's always just
backing up it's backing up it's always
running off hiding whatever the case may
be
because remember Atlantis is very much
this uncharted place of Earth in the
Marvel Universe really only neighbor the
Submariner knows the most about it this
because of the fact that he kept it so
secret and would so often refused to
allow anybody to come down there and so
this of course results in Hydra Captain
America saying fine if he wants to run
and hide then we'll take away his places
to hide and they just bombard Atlantis
with nothing but just Rockets and these
different weapons and so again when a
question is asked whether or not they
need to follow up with the next location
quote-unquote of course Hydra Captain
America's response is no I will take
care of this on my own only for us to
find out that this location is the
current residence of Ultron and all-new
all-different marvel so again they're
all basically going to be meeting up
with Ultron in the next store
at this point I want to kind of
backtrack for a second and I want to
pick up with Sam Wilson because remember
Sam Wilson was the all-new Captain
America
but following Steve Rogers rise in the
reveal that he was a Hydra agent Sam
wasn't basically quit plus it was also
because of the fact that people were
giving him a hard time after a while so
this is one of those situations where he
just says you know what I'm effectively
done and he currently operates as a
smuggler getting people out of the
United States to territories that are
still considered to be free but notice
this is that he points out the fact to
everybody else he says hey I don't know
if you guys noticed but no one's out
fighting in the streets there's no
revolutionary fighters anymore people
have effectively given up and so again
it's one of these funny situations where
it's like if people really cared that
much about their freedom they would
fight for to the bitter end the fact
they're not fighting for it means they
don't care that much about it and if
they don't care that much about it then
their current situation is what they
deserve to have because they're just
rolling over otherwise they would be
fighting against it people don't really
care about who it is that's running the
show so long as things aren't bad for
them and that's not an unreasonable
expectation it's not an unreasonable
stance so long as it can put food on the
table for their kids so long as people
are being rounded up but it's not them
well then suddenly that is it's not a
great big huge deal so again it's one of
these these crazy things were it's like
people sort of you know stick their head
in the ground ignoring a situation
getting worse and worse and then one day
they're going to wake up and just
realize that their life's about as
terrible as it's going to be because
Hydra Captain America made things a lot
worse than they could have been now
following up with Sam Wilson as he's
leading the various you know members of
Tony Stark or I guess hologram Tony
Stark and these other Avengers
revolutionaries out to Brazil where
Ultron's going to be now again for the
most part not all of them know this is
going to be the case but what we end up
doing here is we actually jump back to
Frederik Meijer for the last tale bit in
a story and this is really really cool
because Frederik Meijer the guy who
orchestrated this meeting between Maria
Hill and Natasha Romanov gets up to go
to the bathroom only to find out that
there's a mind planted against the
window or I guess against a glass the
mind goes off and the question is once
he's set upon by whoever it was a plan
of this mind he's question is who are
you what do you want
this guy's response is the best way to
end a story ever he says I could be any
number of things
vengeance terrible and Swift I could be
the guy that could bring everything you
love crashing down around you I'm the
guy who could end your life in a
heartbeat
I could be your punishment and then
Frank
hasil The Punisher says hail Hydra I
told you this is going to be a
cliffhanger with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to it
there if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rod for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you